good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is seek mentors over to
you Robert Kiyosaki if you did not have
the rich dad in your life what would you
be doing today it's hard to say if it
didn't have my Rich Dad because as a
young kid starting up probably about the
age of five six seven eight nine I
really wanted to be rich so I think
number one is desire you know and then
you naturally seek your role models and
teachers and in my lifetime I've had
multiple rich debts you know my rich dad
was my best friend's father's during the
age of nine and then today I still seek
mentors and wise men and wise women
because that's how you get wiser is by
hanging out with smart people I'm a big
believer in mentorship one in terms of
you know face to face people that you
can go and learn from and to from what I
call aspirational mentors people who've
done a lot more than you who you may
never meet who may have passed on but
you can still learn from the success it
comes from the core understanding that
whatever challenge you have in front of
you right now somebody else has already
solved it whatever big problem you're
facing in your life or in your business
somebody has already solved it and you
don't need to come up with every
ingenious solution yourself this is one
of the things that saved my first
business one of the two most important
lessons that I've ever learned in my
life was whenever I don't know what to
do we never have a big problem I don't
know the answer I look for somebody who
has already solved it and I try to learn
from their lessons in my first business
I had a software company I was
struggling you know making $300 a month
barely able to survive and I was just
trying to come up with all these ideas
myself like okay how about we do this
how do we do this how many and nothing
was working and I told my partner I quit
and it was the worst day of my life and
when I woke up the next day I realized I
didn't want to quit I just couldn't keep
going the way I was going and the
lightbulb moment was I realized I'm not
the first guy to try to
software before maybe our specific kind
of software yes but in general other
people have figured out how to sell
software and make lots of money and
target lots of customers how did they do
it and I looked at Bill Gates and how he
got started and that started the process
to me be able to build a real company
and that lesson that I learned that 19
years old has stayed true for the past
almost 20 years where every time I don't
know what to do and look at who can i
model it's it's wide the name of this
channel is modeling the masters it's why
I try to showcase lots of different
successful people from all walks of life
because you can learn from them I'm
learning from them and even today and
all my different businesses earlier this
week I went to SoulCycle with Alex the
SoulCycle is a spinning company that has
a great culture recently came to Toronto
I think they're based in New York might
be LA but they came to Toronto they
opened up a location and I heard so much
about their culture that I thought I'm
trying to build a culture here at TDS we
have a we have of what I think is a
really good culture if you can compare
our culture to most businesses I think
it's amazing but it can always be better
right I want to model even greater
success and so Alex and I went to their
class and we learned from them we saw
how they set up their store and their
merch and how the staff treats you and
how the instructor starts a class and
runs a class and ends a class and what
happens within the locker room like all
the different pieces you learn from them
it doesn't mean you're gonna apply
everything but if you take one lesson
here one lesson here one lesson here
from people and companies that have had
great success it just makes you better
and so I would seek out mentors that you
can meet face to face or you can do now
Google Hangouts with or ask questions
from if anybody is doing a livestream
you get a chance to ask a question I
wish that existed when I was getting
started as an entrepreneur you know you
have so much more access to people than
we've ever had before but even if you're
not going to the direct approach and
hitting somebody look into the
aspirational Mentors finding people
who've done it before even if they
passed on their legacy have left a
series of clues that if you can follow
those clues you can apply it to your
life to your business achieve success
whenever you don't know why
to do instead of trying to figure it all
out yourself understand people have done
it before seek them out learn from them
apply it to your business and you can
have success as well so the question day
today is I'm curious who has been your
biggest mentor either in your personal
life or in your business career who has
been the biggest mentor for you and why
I love to hear from you please share
your thoughts down in the comments below
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Roberto Latini Roberto thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
where you had an early meeting with Dino
De Laurentiis and it didn't go so well
what that was different because Dino De
Laurentiis is an office and he wanted me
to be in dark savage and he wanted me to
play the villain in dark savage and I
walked in and I always kind of you know
have a mouth that sometimes goes a
little bit too fast and the step by
myself there I walked into the office
and they're so Dino standing behind his
desk and there was this huge desk ornate
gold and kind of like French looking or
Italian looking I don't know what but it
was gigantic it was one of this partner
desks right and Dino the only thing that
stood out was kind of his chest and his
head because he's a little guy Dean is a
really short so I looked in and I walked
in his office and I looked in his hi
Tina
why does a little guy like you need such
a big desk and too thin of the
horrendous you never say you little
right because he saw himself as a giant
so he looked at me and he says ah I
smarts in Agra you have an accent I
cannot use it you
and I said again stupidly who was
talking about having an accent I mean
listen to you ah are you a Nazi ah you
know he walked he walked away because at
the German accent said there was the end
of that so I left the office and my
agent came up to me grabbed me really
forceful with my arm and he said to me
says I have been an agent for 15 years
this meeting was exactly one minute and
14 seconds it was the shortest meeting
they've ever had
you just everything I've got them and it
took me months to get in here so he was
mad at me also so anyway so that's so
that's how the relationship started
Medina but then when he bought Conan he
came to Spain where we were shooting and
the third day of filming after he saw
the dailies the footage should be a film
he came up to me and he said there's
rats in Agra you were Conan and he
walked off and and Milius came to me the
director he says this is the greatest
compliment that he can ever get he said
you're Conan isn't that great yeah I
guess so
and from that point on we created this
really great relationship and we did
movies together and Roy deal and then
red Sonia and Conan the Destroyer and
Conan of a parent and and there he was
became kind of like a father figure he
became kind of the rich Park that I had
in a body building world in Joe Weider
he became that character in a movie
world that I could go to for anything
who would give me advice who always had
wonderful compliments and kind of took
me in as part of his family
and so that's why I always will miss him
very dearly after they passed away how
do we find our personal Kirk camp Myers
somebody who can really speak into our
lives and change our trajectory well I I
can't take credit for it I went to a
seminar the Kurt was teaching on success
and when he was when they finished
teaching I went up to him and introduced
myself and I asked for an appointment
with him and and he came to
then the Lancaster through the holiday
and for breakfast and we had that
breakfast meeting that did change my
life and then I never saw him again from
that time until my 65th birthday would
my staff brah I never had seen him I
talked about him and talked about and on
my 65th birthday when we were having a
party together they brought him into the
room and I haven't seen him for 40 years
I just wept and I thought you know but
but I think the key was when I went to
hear him and I he began to speak to my
life about being successful I I kind of
broke out of a barrier and I went up to
introduce myself and then I asked could
I take him to breakfast and could I
learn from him and I think the key is
once you see somebody that is helping
you be bold and ask them you know can I
take you to breakfast and by the way
here's the thought by the breakfast okay
just don't go and say hey how about
buying breakfast for me though but but
just I I took that step and I've always
been glad I took that step but I've
always thought to myself you know what
if I wouldn't have taken the step then I
probably would have never had that
relationship whenever maybe would I ask
that question whomever would never would
have had this seminar or would have
written written the book so I think once
you see somebody that you think can
really help you take the initiative and
step right